john we are taking in these images
uh together as we heard there from
border patrol and to remind everyone
that
uh the latest numbers showed almost 6
000 children in border patrol
border control custody at this time
and it's it's it really stops you
in your tracks when you watch this and
you see these overcrowded facilities
babies toddlers children of all ages
that are there and they're in the middle
of what is a crisis at our southern
border with numbers that continue
to surge and a struggle for our country
to deal with this
situation john yeah you know when you
when you think about the total current
population there at this donna texas
facility and again the pictures are
blurred so that you can't read what's on
the screen
4 100 there right now 3 400 of those
people who are in this facility are
unaccompanied migrant children
again the capacity during a pandemic for
that facility
is 250 uh so they are way way way
over capacity and and also because
people are supposed to
come into this facility stay a maximum
period of 72 hours and then be
transferred to hhs
custody that's not happening quickly
enough so more than 2 000 people
at this facility have been held for
longer than 72
hours which if you'll remember happened
during the trump administration
and was the subject of outrage by
immigrants rights groups other political
parties
were were screaming from the rooftops
about how awful this was and yet we do
not hear the same level of outrage
over this happening now in this new
administration and you're reminded that
this is all happening as you just
mentioned john in the middle of a
pandemic
uh where there's concern about kovid
being brought across the border
at a time when we're trying to get a
hold of the situation here
and by the images that we just brought
you from inside this facility john where
when you came in on the wash the migrant
having
her hair washed that was to check for
lice it reminds you of how many
other other screenings have to take
place to safely
cram this many people together if that's
even possible
but then to add to it covid19
what do you do and as you heard deputy
chief ortiz say
uh that you know the the people who come
across the border
particularly migrant unaccompanied uh
children
are interviewed to see if they were
victims of human trafficking
well you know congressman lance gooden
who was on earlier this hour said
one way to figure that out very quickly
would be to pass his new bill which
would require that every person who
comes across the border
has their dna sampled and then is
checked with the person that they come
across
the border with to see if these if these
unaccompanied children
uh or rather children who are coming
across in an ostensible quote family
unit
actually are with their family let's
listen in just a little more here
sometimes
yes yes and there's only one there's so
there's four
four of these right now but on a regular
basis is this about how many you have
there's a there's usually between five
and seven eight
okay so there you see a number of uh
migrant children i assume that these
would be unaccompanied minors who are
being moved from the intake facility
through to what would be the housing
facility i think that we're going to get
some pictures
uh from in there uh you're watching this
on a replay it came in live
a few minutes ago but we wanted to see
what was on it
and this again another view of the
intake facility you can see people
sitting on benches waiting their turn
to be processed by the border patrol but
the real story i think sandra will be
told if we get
inside that area where
the illegal migrants are being housed
which are the pictures
that henry cuellar's office leaked out a
little more than a week ago
and the pictures that ted cruz was
trying to get
when he had that administration official
getting up in his face saying
please stop taking pictures stop taking
pictures so
this area here uh is
fairly sparsely populated but i think if
they get inside
to the areas where the migrants are
actually being housed you might see a
little more overcrowding
don it's so important to to see these
pictures
as we saw in the first biden news
conference last week
where he took many questions on this he
was pressed on the lack of transparency
on the part of his administration
why we are not seeing inside these
facilities what is going on there
because as you can see
when we watch this together it does give
you perspective on what this
is like for the border patrol to manage
this influx of children
to manage a surge in migrants that are
coming to our border in just the last
couple of months it is unprecedented
john and for us to see firsthand and
take these images in together
it tells the story that is happening
right now
as americans we take in these pictures
and we ask
what about a visit we know kamala harris
has been put in charge
of the border situation we were told
although it sounds more like she's going
to be dealing this
with the countries from which these
migrants come rather than directly with
the border crisis
whether or not we will see a visit on
the part of kamala harris
joe biden we know that gensake is
grilled on this
every day in that briefing room we still
don't have an answer to that question
but seeing these images certainly puts
the urgency on it if you didn't already
understand what was happening inside
john yeah and keep in mind too sandra
that there are two
different types of facilities this is a
border patrol
intake and processing facility this one
was uh
contracted on january the 15th
construction began on january the 19th
and it opened up a few weeks ago
it's rather expensive it cost six
million dollars to build
and 16 million dollars a month to
operate because they are operating
way way way over capacity now from here
the children will be i mean well a
number of things happen
first of all there are two flights per
day that leave this facility each flight
holds about 130 people
a lot of those are migrant families one
flight goes to el paso
another flight goes to san diego where
then people are further processed some
of them are returned to mexico
under title 42 exclusion others may be
transferred to other places within the
country so this is border patrol
but then we we hear about this facility
in carrizo springs which was set up
stood up during the
trump administration that is an hhs
health and human services
facility where unaccompanied minor
children go
to stay until a sponsor can be found to
take them
in while their asylum claim is
adjudicated and they're either reunited
with their family
in the united states or family members
or sponsors in the united states
or return back to their home to be
reunited with families so
this is the border patrol facility this
is the one
that is full to bursting the carrizo
springs facility
which we saw pictures of last week uh is
not
full to capacity it's what's known as
quote an aspirational facility
uh because there have yet to be a large
number of people have been transferred
to that facility